[Music]
now onto some Grammy news Kelly Clarkson
Miley Cyrus Rita Ora and bebe Rexha are
leading the music industry charge to
wear white roses to the Grammys to show
solidarity with the times up movement
now we have learned that the word is
spreading quickly and even more stars
are expected to sign on meanwhile we've
got more news coming from the host of
music's biggest night Cameron Mathison
is hanging out in our absolute
lime-green room with more on the story
James Corden is back as the host with
the most for the 60th annual Grammy
Awards in our quell teen I caught up
with him today in New York and he let us
you know what we can expect what do we
have in store for Sunday night we're not
doing like a big sort of opening or
anything there's a very very very big
performance at the start of the show so
we have a couple of things planned a
couple of things just still waiting the
air on if we can pull it off and then
and then we'll see the red carpets
rolled out and the seating cards are up
for Grammys big return to New York the
first in 15 years but will there be more
carpool karaoke
I know Beyonce's on your bucket list is
she gonna be on the Grammy bucket list
will she perform this year she won't be
performing this year no no she performed
last year do you still get nervous at
this stuff
nervous all the time I'm never not
nervous so yes I'll be terrified
watch James take the Grammy stage this
Sunday on CBS of course absolutely I am
is back as the official spirit sponsor
for the 60th annual Grammy Award the
latest flavor has no sugar added and no
artificial flavor
[Music]
you